I love overdrafting my bank account what
yeah because it makes us both feel poor
when news hits I can break it fast I can
talk about those things because I love
researching it I sold my portfolio in
January and I got a lot of hate because
people were saying why would you go into
Cash during some of the worst inflation
ever like because I'm not buying food or
groceries or gas with my cash I'm buying
assets I'm a probably the biggest
proponent of Bitcoin I'm worried that
once the ethereum lockups occur we're
going to actually really see a crash in
ethereum what's the one thing in
financial markets right now that you
think is really really important but you
feel like other people aren't talking
about aren't paying attention to all
right guys bang bang uh I'm here with me
Kevin I've got a question to start off
uh I heard a rumor that while you're
recording you actually are editing the
video and cutting at the same time is
that true some live streams I'll do that
so uh for example if I switch to like
CNBC or it's Jerome Powell talking I
could be it could already be cutting
kind of how like parts that I want to
have in the video so absolutely so
you're literally talking to the camera
uh in an articulate Manner and also at
the same time basically running the
control room yeah exactly yeah yeah my
goal is to have as little friction as
possible so I can you know switch angles
or stop pause recordings and text
messages you know whatever I get it and
how did you build that skill set like I
think most people would be like hey just
recording live is hard enough but also
to be able to cut the videos what the
hell's going on yeah I mean I I think I
attribute some of it to just in speech
and debate in high school sometimes we
would get a topic in sort of a final
round of uh or Congressional debate it
was like okay now we're going to talk
about this topic go and so we have to
debate with no prep and talk coherently
and so I think that helped a lot uh with
speaking live but then actually like
editing or or even just refining the way
I want to put my videos together I mean
that just took years of trial and error
it went from you know one camera with
the SD card to having a live switch or
no more SD card let's get rid of the
battery everything that got in the way I
just wanted to get rid of so now I just
walk in I go Alexa office on and lights
are on the recording's on press record
boom
you wired it all too it's all wired to
Alexa because really what what I want is
I want to my most enjoyable part is
actually talking to the camera and
filming my least enjoyable part is
editing so my goal is if I spend more
than five minutes editing I'm unhappy so
my goal is less than that like yeah I
just want it posted do you worry that
Jeff Bezos is listening oh I know there
are all listening it's very scary it's
so weird because I'll talk about certain
brands uh you know oh we're doing a Nike
fundamental analysis or whatever sure
enough then I'm on Amazon everything's
Nike you know it's scary they are
they're definitely listening so when
somebody asks you like what do you do
for a living do you say that you're a
YouTuber an entrepreneur you [ __ ] around
on the internet like how do you describe
like the strategy that you're employing
usually I say real estate so and the
reason I do that is uh I always try to
kind of downplay what I've got going on
because I I don't love the whole like oh
you what kind of Channel what do you do
yeah so I I usually say Oh Real Estate
you know sales and things like that and
I mean those are both true student sales
are accurate but uh yeah I mean
sometimes it comes up in discussion but
uh uh I try to keep it simple if you go
back and you look at your early YouTube
videos like what is the most
cringe-worthy part and then what's the
part where you're like man now I got
that right or like that really serves as
the foundation for which I ended up
building yeah I I think going back to
some of my original videos I was very
critical of of other uh creators in the
real estate space and I wish I had been
a little bit less critical because that
leads to problems and uh really you
could do well in social media without
just always being negative about
something else and so that was probably
if I could go back that's one thing I
would do differently uh now you could
still be critical but have a nice
positive message like for example when I
first reviewed Grant cardone's uh
syndications and that I I started out
with hey this is a brilliant business
model here are the fees here's how it
works and it would do explanatory videos
those I'm very proud of those sort of
original videos but then when it
devolves into like oh now cardone's
doing this you know that's that's when
it it doesn't get too good so that's not
a cringe and so like let's go through
the different asset classes right so if
you look at uh stocks real estate and
crypto it feels like you touch on all
three of those uh and that's really kind
of the full thing you're looking at
you're not really looking at lots of
venture capital or private Equity or
commodities it's pretty much those three
is the area that you evaluate yeah
generally I I'm I don't know enough
about private Equity to really go at
least at this point to really go deep
into those so I try my best to stick to
what can I talk about without any prep
because that's where when news hits I
can break it fast so for example if
somebody at the FED says something I
have so much in my memory bank of
everything else that's been said or done
at the FED over the last two decades I
could easily start talking about that we
could start talking about you know
opportunistic disinflation in the 80s
which is something maybe we'll see again
who knows we can talk about the FED but
I can talk about those things because I
love researching it so if I get asked
about Venture Capital I'm a little bit
more in the dark yeah what do you think
is going on at the FED do you think they
actually have control of what the
situation or do you think that they uh
have kind of lost control and they're
along for the ride like the rest of us
the problem with the FED right now is
they've got this big credibility
challenges so they've got to act tough
because they have to talk the market
down and I'm worried about that because
really the best thing that could happen
in my opinion would be inflation
plummets to like five or four percent
but then they relax right they they okay
okay we're trending down let's be
patient now let's let us let's let the
big drop go from eight to five percent
four percent and just let it taper out
but the problem is they've talked so
hardcore about getting us to two percent
that they might just have to keep the
screws tight and and they'll push us
into deflation which I think is terrible
so they'll over tighten because they
have to from a credibility point of view
back in the 80s when they went through
this in the 90s they let inflation go
from from double digits down to four or
five percent but they let that ride for
15 years it took 15 years to go from
five percent inflation to two percent
inflation If the Fed did that now with
how much they're like we won't stop
until we get to two percent they'd have
again no credibility and so now they
have to keep the screws tight longer and
I think that's bad for all asset classes
in the short term certainly creates an
opportunity though especially real
estate yeah when you think of that
specific strategy it feels like uh
between March of 2020 and maybe November
December of 2021 kind of that 18-month
time frame good times people were just
drunk right uh they were still
conducting asset purchases they still
had interest rates at zero uh all the
way even into the beginning of 2022 even
though inflation was over seven percent
right and so they kind of over rotated
there well you're basically what maybe
warning about or calling out is that
look uh even if inflation starts to come
down it doesn't seem like they're going
to stop tightening Financial conditions
and so you're worried about them over
rotating in the other direction yeah and
not only am I worried about them over
rotating but I'm also worried that even
though we could get to a level of four
percent inflation let's say which isn't
shown to be bad for the economy it's
it's a I mean there are no studies that
say four percent inflation is somehow
devastating that we have to tighten the
screws but because they've backed
themselves into this corner we won't
stop until we we get to two percent
that's where I'm worried that sure now
it looks like they're over tightening
see what it feels like when we're at
four percent inflation and they're not
relenting that's the part where I'm
worried about we're all everybody's
right now hoping for the relent right
when are they gonna U-Turn when are they
going to pause but what if they don't
how do you think about the FED uh
continuing to tighten both the Federal
Reserve in the United States but central
banks around the world are all kind of
following uh the fed's lead and saying
look we will create these tighter
Financial conditions but we've also seen
the United States are shipping billions
of dollars to Ukraine we've seen in the
UK uh let them talk about these tax cuts
we've seen many other kind of loose
fiscal policy around the world and it
feels like the central banks and the
politicians are in like a proxy war
almost uh or like an indirect war with
each other can we create looser
conditions or can we create uh tighter
Financial conditions one who wins and
two like do they even realize that
they're fighting this war with each
other you know I think uh politics and
and uh monetary policy are so terrible
they should never be you know we can
competing with each other but that's
exactly what's happening for example in
England now you've got their new prime
minister and they're essentially
treasury secretary going let's have the
largest tax cuts for the wealthy and
have this policy of trickle-down
Economics which you know as an
entrepreneur I'm like this is great like
hopefully that inspires that in America
because I'm a big fan of lower taxes
because I'm paying 55 in taxes in
California I need to move here to
Florida right but so when I hear them
talk about hey we're a country of
entrepreneurs let's cut taxes that's
great for an entrepreneur but that's
going to hurt people who are suffering
the most from inflation in the short
term and it's also now stimulating their
economy at a time when inflation's
already a double digits double-digit
levels we don't need more of that right
now we need less of that so you're right
you've got this weird aspect of stimulus
while tightening happening and all
that's going to do is continue to make
the dollar stronger relative to the
pound for example at the same time China
is is stimulating because they're
probably in a depression even though
their official number numbers are still
two to four percent growth I don't
believe it I think they're in a
depression uh you do have a very weird
situation though where the I don't think
we're ever going to be in a situation
again where the dollar is so relatively
strong because we're the only economy
that's actually going to get through
this I think relatively unscathed now I
shouldn't say unscathed because there
are going to be a lot of people who lose
their jobs and suffer but we're going to
have companies with corporate earnings
that are still phenomenally strong but
we're still going to be what feels like
going through a long recession most of
the leaders in America keep pointing to
the strong labor market even housing
growth
um in some of the recent comments uh
Jerome Powell said hey I think you use
the word pain over and over and over
again and he was talking about look
we're gonna have to have a uh maybe not
as strong of a labor market we're going
to see housing prices come down and even
uh some sort of corrective period is
necessary to get this inflation down do
you feel like the market really is
taking it seriously and pricing in the
fact that uh in uh unemployment could go
from 3.6 3.7 percent to five percent or
do you feel like people are kind of
let's call this Bluff and see if we're
really going to get there yeah the
market is expecting the FED to U-turn
the market has always bottomed out when
the FED u-turns bottomed out in 89 it
bottomed out in uh March of 2003 and
bottomed out in 2009 in February it
bottomed out in December of 2018
bottomed out in March of 2020. all of
those bottoms aligned with fed policy
not Congress passing some stimulus bill
it aligned with fed policy you turning
on rates or promising unlimited bailouts
like what we saw not only in 89 when
they first created the standard of
bailing out markets but also in March of
2020 those were the bottoms March 23rd
never forget the day bad bailouts
infinite bailout will bail out corporate
bonds it will buy everything and so the
market now is wise to that and so the
market is trying to regularly price in
this idea of okay well as soon as the
FED u-turns that's the bottom so let's
try to find the bottom before that so
we're there's a lot of this Euphoria and
optimism that okay well they're going to
turn around soon the problem is they're
not and they're they probably won't so
we're probably going to go through as
Jerome Powell puts at that pain for a
lot longer I personally think that it
creates phenomenal buying opportunities
you know at the beginning of this year I
said the best asset was was Cash uh and
and I sold my portfolio I bought back in
way too early but I sold my portfolio in
January and I got a lot of hate because
people were saying why would you go into
Cash during some of the worst inflation
ever like because I'm not buying food or
groceries or gas with my my cash I'm
buying assets and assets go down when
the FED fights inflation so I want to
hoard cash to buy stocks at discounted
levels or or real estate which is what
we're doing now hoarding Cash For Real
Estate so uh there are opportunities in
that but uh yeah do you know we're gonna
I think we still have a good amount of
pain ahead before the Market's fully
realize this is not going to be a Fed
that u-turns as quickly as we thought
yeah why did you go back into the market
like what was the thought process there
and then now given kind of hindsight uh
being 2020 what do you think you either
got wrong or misjudged or whatever yeah
so the reason I got back into the market
is I actually went 90 and this sounds
this is not Financial advice even though
I passed my has to be a financial
advisor this by no means I could I could
not recommend this to anyone I went 90
into Tesla and the reason I did that was
because Tesla was between uh my
purchases were between 630 and about 800
pre-split and uh the reason I went into
Tesla was be around the fear of uh not
only the Shanghai shutdowns that we had
this summer but also this idea that
potentially Tesla could survive the
coming earnings recession and so I
believe we're going to see companies
like we just saw Nike reported again
their uh last quarter their net earnings
were down five percent now they're like
down 21 on net earnings their margins
are getting squeezed their inventory is
so high they're having to Discount all
this excess inventory massively ahead of
the holiday season it's terrible for
earnings Tesla on the other hand even
they have so much excess demand that
even if we kill 20 or 30 percent of the
excess demand we have for Tesla they're
still going to sell every car they can
produce so Tesla's in this very unique
situation where we'll be going through
in my opinion this this bottoming of
earnings for a lot of companies through
an earnings recession where people will
then look and go wait a minute Tesla
earnings though are still going up I
think we've already seen the multiple
compression price to earnings multiple
compression now it's just the earnings
recession we got to get through and I
believe Tesla will actually come out of
this recession at a higher price than
than it was substantially before so uh
so I moved into Tesla now we'll see if
that ends up being the right move or not
I think Q3 Q4 earnings are going to be
phenomenal and and every other company
most other companies are going to be
pretty miserable I think if there was
another company that is going to do well
for the next or another couple companies
that are going to do well for the next
couple quarters they'd be American
Express which I just found not only are
they hiring like crazy but they've got a
huge office I think their headquarters
is here at Sunrise which is amazing I'm
like I want to buy homes and rent them
out to American Express people here
right uh and end phase but uh in Phase
the the Solar Company uh for for
inverters I think they're going to get
hit when housing gets hit
see Home Depot tells us that when people
spend money on their homes and prices
are going up it's an investment when
people spend money on their homes and
prices are going down it's an expense
it's a great line from a Home Depot
earnings report so I think that's where
Enphase could end up getting hit and
they've done really well I think they're
positive here today which is great but
uh it'll come so anyway I'm like 90 of
Tesla uh what's the other 10 percent
miscellaneous basket so that's like uh
that is some exposure to end face I
wanted to get back into the chips so I
started buying back into the chips
although that ended up being they ended
up having a lot more pain than anyone
expected so so that's not so great cyber
security some crowd strikes Cloud
players some of those how do you think
about allocating in these types of
environments to stocks versus
um real estate versus uh Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies uh well in in these
environments where uh everything is
getting crushed so badly I love that we
can now buy companies at Great
valuations in my opinion or much better
valuations so I love the idea of of
hooking into some of those lower
valuations on companies and then when we
get into maybe coming out of these
recessions some more euphoric times then
I like going more into I'd like to call
more of the spec assets right where okay
well you know hey how's the cardano
right you know or or Bitcoin or whatever
that's when I generally like to broaden
out to those is more of uh more of a hey
it's boom Time Yeah you mentioned
earlier uh the word recession obviously
there seems to be a debate
I joke that uh one of the new Wars in
culture is literally in the dictionary
right of like what are the what are the
definitions of these words uh I think
you and I probably say hey a recession
is two consecutive quarters of negative
GDP growth uh which we have yes
um so put aside for a second the
conversation in terms of are we in a
recession are we not
um do you expect it to continue to get
much much worse and if so is it sector
by sector you're analyzing this or do
you look at this as all one big trade
where all assets kind of correlations go
towards one and we'll just see assets
bleed it'll matter if you're in stocks
you know large cap micro cap if you're
in real estate Commodities like this is
all just one big trade in the Pheasant
control yeah there are definitely
differences I think Commodities are
going to continue their plummet uh oil
is going to come down more especially
with China collapsing you know I mean
their economy is already so slowed down
it's already helped oil drive oil down a
lot natural gas once we get through this
winter with Europe natural gas prices
will come down substantially uh you know
Italy just got cut off from Russia right
so they're importing with ships and it's
like oh great now we gotta get natural
gas from other places so the Commodities
will come down used car prices will come
down uh iron steel all of these
Commodities will come down except for
lithium lithium probably will continue
to do quite well
um stocks and cryptos I think will be
relatively aligned and it doesn't even
matter in my opinion if you're in
discretionaries or Staples or what I
think they they are going to be
relatively on a similar ride
as far as real estate though there'll be
a big lag in my opinion see the stock
market last bottomed in in the last
large recession in 2009 yeah we bottomed
out somewhere in the earlier part of
2009 like February real estate didn't
bottom until November of 2011. and so
there's this really unique opportunity
in my opinion where I think
stocks will trough and start rising and
stocks will rise as real estate is
really starting to show year-over-year
declines and stocks in my opinion my
crystal ball says will be at nice more
uh normalized levels not at the pit of
the market anymore as real estate
bottoms and so I think there's this
opportunity to ride a company like Tesla
for example where you could survive an
earnings recession in my opinion could
be wrong ride that and then as real
estate troughs move that money from
there into real estate generally I think
a lot of people if you have a net worth
of under 500 000 you should you're the
first investment you should make is your
own home get into real estate uh and
then I'm a big fan of diversifying maybe
50 real estate and then 50 stocks in
crypto so it's interesting you say that
because I know there's a lot of other
guys who have pretty big uh YouTube
channels or kind of public commentary uh
and one of the talking points they love
to hammer home is like don't buy fire
home rented right to talk a little bit
in terms of the pros and cons of buying
versus renting and why you feel like uh
uh it's better to actually go ahead and
purchase it today's episode is brought
to you by Alto I all right have you
wanted to buy Bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with Alto Ira
they allow you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantage way
there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to Alto ira.com to get started
Alto ira.com
invest in Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies Alto ira.com yeah so
so the biggest way to wealth or easiest
way in my opinion to wealth is home
ownership if we look at the average net
worth of a tenant it's five to seven
thousand dollars average net worth of a
homeowner is around 200 000 right now
it's it's incredible uh and and there's
a very simple reason for that it's if
you just buy a home even if it's five or
ten percent down and the payment is even
remotely similar to what the rent would
be you have to pay to live somewhere so
if you're paying two thousand dollars a
month uh rent a place or two thousand
dollars a month to own a home one of the
beautiful things here is the first easy
difference you have is principal paydown
you are paying that property off in 30
years you'll own it so every single
month that's like a four savings account
and if there's one thing that Americans
are really bad at it's saving but
because you have to make that payment
you're actually forcing yourself to save
and the neat thing is the payment stays
fixed minus you know insurance and
property taxes and that the payment
stays fixed so your payment on a home or
for 30 years barely goes up whereas rent
goes up at least generally with
inflation or more uh and of course the
home value goes up because the rents are
going up so your payment is staying the
same for an asset that's actually
growing in value and you're avoiding the
danger of having rent increases every
single year now I know people make this
argument that oh but a home's not
investment yeah it is a phenomenal
investment but you can definitely make
it not an investment see where people go
wrong is they go oh well you know if I'm
going to remodel my home I may as well
do the high-end kitchen or the high-end
bathrooms and the Tesla solar roof all
those things are a rip-off
should do the bare minimum to and we
don't want to sound like a slum Lord but
you want to do the bare minimum to to
make a house healthy uh like health and
safety standards bring those standards
up and move in Ready Rental grade maybe
a little bit above rental grade and it's
something that you can live in you can
rent out you can Airbnb you have
flexibility and this is something that
you could grow your wealth with not only
that but as your wealth grows you can
get a credit line against that and go
buy another home or do something that I
like to do is two things I like to do
one thing is bank hacking you buy a
place for three and a half or five
percent down live there for a year do it
again and do it again and do it again
and all of a sudden you could have four
or five properties by the you know if
you started when you were 25 by the time
you're 40 you could easily have four or
five ten properties that you just moved
around it and eventually you stop moving
a lot of people want to wait until they
have a family terrible idea moving with
kids is a nightmare I got two kids I
don't want to move the best time to move
is when you're young if you're in
college right you can rent out the other
rooms and help you make the payment
great you can get a fixer-upper at that
second favorite thing I like to do and
and you could buy I just looked at a
foreclosure in Pembroke Pines just this
morning
it was listed for 450 000 sold for I
think four hundred twenty thousand
dollars and it's in a 650 000
neighborhood sure it needs work needs
about eighty thousand dollars worth of
work but even a first time home buyer
can call up the bank and say I need a
renovation loan on this so you're into
the deal for 500 in a 650 000
neighborhood your net worth just went up
by 150 000 like where else can you do
that if you're buying and you're getting
into it for five percent down which
could be you know twenty to Thirty forty
thousand dollars of your own money
that's a huge move in your network so
real estate you gotta own it yeah when
you start to think
the stock market specifically you're
very very heavy weight there compared to
real estate uh do you try to trade the
home uh values and kind of market
dynamics talking about hey I'm going to
be allocated to Tesla and then I'm going
to go back into uh uh home ownership or
kind of real estate like how do you
think about going in and out and really
get to the question of like when do you
know to sell assets versus just hold
them forever yeah so this this is
something that's changed because of very
unique circumstances for me and I'll
explain those but I generally don't
recommend selling real estate unless
you're going to exchange it or just keep
it forever because then you in theory
could never pay taxes that's the
beautiful thing about home ownership is
you could have a whole rental portfolio
never pay a dime of taxes because when
that day comes you pass away you can
pass it on to your family they get a
stepped up tax place they never pay
taxes on it it's incredible and there
are ways to not pay taxes while you're
alive too so there's some wonderful ways
and reasons to never sell real estate
so I love the idea of don't sell however
the real same macro cycle exists it goes
up and down and so I sold 85 of my
properties we had 27 properties in
Southern California I sold 85 in the
first half of this year and the reason I
did I have no tenants right now which is
remarkable it's like I mean like the New
York Times labels me a landlord
influencer yet I have no tenants I'm not
a landlord and it's so weird to say uh
but the reason I did that is because I
knew we were going to start this uh real
estate company house hack and so I
thought let me sell my real estate move
all that money into this company because
that's that's my dream that's my goal
that's what I want to do it's what I
want to create and now we're just going
to sit and wait and buy real estate once
we think it gets closer to bottom and
that trend is working so I believe I
sold relatively close to the top in real
estate and I think I'll be able to buy
relatively close to a low in in real
estate I'm not that perfect at all with
stocks right I mean I sold in January I
was back in the market by the summer
right now in hindsight I'm like damn I
wish I just didn't get back and just sit
on cash we'll see maybe maybe Tesla
it'll it'll work out in terms of the
earnings recession play but for most
people I think
trying to move in and out is just a bad
idea you know I sit and study the macro
cycle every single day and it's hard for
for even me I can't pull it off in
stocks uh I think real estate's a little
easier because it moves so slowly so
um I think that's also why
now not to go into so many different
topics but we're launching three
exchange traded funds is because the
neat thing with those is when we trade
stocks within those and let's say if I
personally am just holding the ticker I
never pay taxes on trades that happen
within it uh the beautiful thing about
that is
anytime you can trade out of a stock
that's run and not pay taxes oh that's a
wonderful opportunity and ETFs give you
that opportunity uh otherwise if you
sold a stock that ran to a euphoric
level you you'd be paying capital gains
on it how much of the time that you
spend looking at the market is on macro
versus on what I'll call more like asset
class evaluation versus just tax uh
mitigation well with tax mitigation vary
a little time because that's just uh is
what it is I mean once you understand
the the tax game then that just becomes
sort of a side note and an analysis what
are things you do there like like what
are the practical things that people at
home are like okay he obviously looks at
all this stuff like what are some of the
things that you're like yeah this is the
easy stuff to get started with and then
maybe what's the most exotic thing you
do on the tax side sure okay so uh on
tax side or just announced or both okay
so taxes uh okay so I mean the easy
stuff is everybody should have like a
side hustle because if everybody has a
side hustle and as long as there's an
intent to earn income with that side
hustle or ID deal you actually earn some
income anything that you would
ordinarily be spending money on could be
a write-off like a phone is a necessary
and ordinary expense for an entrepreneur
but if you're an employee and you're
paying your own phone bill 100 a month
you're paying a hundred dollars a month
in after tax money if you happen to have
a side hustle and now you can write off
that hundred dollars a month well now
you're saving in some cases 50 so it's
like getting a 50 off coupon code on all
of these crazy expenses your car your
phone that laptop that you need you know
what need Frank whatever like these are
uh that I think bare minimum everybody
should have some form of a side hustle
for that purpose
uh you know as far as getting creative
uh I think the I mean I don't think it's
that creative but I think a wonderful
thing everybody should do is maximize
their Roth contributions every single
year if they end up buying a car hey if
it's over a certain weight you can
almost fully write off some of these
vehicles some huge tax deductions there
although I do think cars are a very bad
investment unless you're into Exotics
and you're like a professional into that
I think cars are a terrible investment I
always say buy the stock not the not the
car but um that's the most exotic thing
you do is call right off and uh uh 401ks
or Roth irons oh well that that's I
wouldn't say that's more exotic I think
that's more like Baseline right I think
exotic would be like what we were
looking at last year which was I had a
an 11 million dollar tax bill last year
and I would have loved to have bought a
plane uh because I could have written
off I mean I I could have avoided about
90 of those taxes if I bought a plane
the problem with that is and it's the
reason I didn't buy a plane is I thought
well and I didn't know this in November
but I'm like well things are great now
but what if we go into a recession next
year or a few years down the road which
here we are in a recession uh you know
now you have to pay for a plane and
that's insane I mean the cost I mean
it's millions of dollars a year and
pilots and Hangar fees and maintenance
it's terrible so uh I decided to just
eat bite the bullet and pay the taxes uh
some you paid 11 million in taxes and
Elon paid 11 billion I think so like
yeah exactly you're getting your way
towards uh towards the alarm exactly
we're basically Brothers man we're step
Bros
so it's like it's interesting right
because uh if you're paying that size of
a tax bill why don't you spend more time
on trying to mitigate it is it just sure
you're just more interested in how do I
create more income or like oh no no I
think there are great ways to to
mitigate it even even just buying real
estate I mean I looked at apartment
buildings at the end of last year uh
starting in in September I'm like gosh I
should just buy a few 10 million dollar
buildings which you just Finance you
know with three million dollars down and
finance it you take and then you cost
segregate it you're taking a write-off
on on a bulk of the building uh and
you're only putting a fraction of the
percent down you do the same thing with
a plane you put like 15 down on a plane
right it's remarkable financing is a
cool thing when it comes to tax benefits
so that's where it gets a little bit
more exotic
but uh I decided not to because I was
looking at all the apartment buildings
that I wanted to buy them like these
valuations are insane no I didn't
actually think we were about to walk
into a real estate recession because I
don't think anybody in November thought
the Fed was going to go this dirty so
obviously things changed well and they
had talked I think tough before and not
really followed through exactly this was
the time where they were like okay cool
uh we're gonna talk tough and then I by
maybe January February I think we were
like oh I think they're really serious
and then by March I think was the first
uh interest rate hike if you're like oh
here we go oh yeah and since then it's
just been pain oh absolutely yeah it's
uh I think I I remember back on January
5th it was just January 5th or sixth I
reviewed uh the Federal Reserve minutes
for December and that was the first time
their tones started changing in their
minutes their tone change they didn't
actually change their actions until like
you say Marge which is so ridiculous
that as you said earlier they were still
printing money through like March and
April that's so dumb almost so dumb but
their tone changed in December and it
was so bad I think I uh the title of my
video and I know a lot of the titles my
videos are aggressive and dramatic but
that one was the worst fed report or
most disastrous fed report I've ever
read and I spent an hour on a live
stream just reading how their tone was
changing but even after reading through
that I don't think anybody actually
believed that the transitory Fed was
about to go dirty on us and and here we
are you're going dirty on us is the main
platform for the content on YouTube or
do you have other platforms YouTube and
talk a little bit about uh the content
you create there and like what have you
learned over the years and why stay on
that platform when Tick Tock is rising
or these other platforms seem to kind of
come and go in popularity uh well
YouTube pays
uh I mean just honestly there are people
who get millions of views on on Tick
Tock they could get 10 million views a
month on Tick Tock and earn 200 bucks uh
in in ad Revenue whereas 10 million
views on YouTube could could pay uh uh
you know a hundred thousand dollars it's
it's insane the differences so that's
certainly a driver YouTube's where I
built my audience so I I like providing
value where I started uh so it's not
always just about numbers I mean there's
a business sense to that if I'm gonna
sit down and decide well do I want to
spend an hour making tick tocks for an
hour making a good YouTube video I'd
rather make a YouTube video because it
makes sense it financially is
incentivizing but uh beyond that uh you
know I've tried so many different things
but one of the things I realized is
Kevin just do what's been working keep
providing value about the macro Market
or real estate or whatever on a daily
basis on your channel and yeah look I
post a lot more and I don't edit my
videos you know some people are like
well why why don't you spend more time
and like just post three times a week
and then do like a high quality video
where you're like doing the punch ins
and the music and the sound and all this
and I've personally found that I don't
think my audience cares I think they're
like Kevin we just want the information
we don't need all the The Glitz and Glam
or whatever that maybe uh channel that
caters more to uh 16 to 18 year old
cares about where oh this is so cool and
engaging oh I'm not gonna click off
because there are some you know memes or
whatever that popped up that's fine that
works for a lot of people my audience
gets pissed off they're like Kevin this
is annoying yeah do you have you have
one channel or multiple channels I've
tried multiple channels it's never
worked for me so it's just me Kevin
that's it that's where I post and I I
don't need any other platforms I you
know I'll still occasionally post a tick
tock uh you know Nancy Pelosi's trades
can't believe she did this right before
the stock plummeted she saw you know
let's always do well I mean it is crazy
yeah it is crazy she's obviously one
example but uh the fact that we have uh
fed presidents that were day trading
assets that the Fed was actively engaged
in buying uh we have politicians who are
buying and selling assets uh and it's
unclear I think part of what I think
makes people really upset is that they
don't know what information uh certain
people had uh and so like that's kind of
crazy
um and then even if you go and you look
like there are disclosure rules and
things like that in the public markets
but there's still many examples of like
some kind of crazy behavior that we've
seen people go through and and
um I don't know what the answer is
because like completely Banning
ownership feels like a pretty aggressive
step and uh uh in some ways you don't
want a a ton of people with no assets to
be politicians right because then
they're worried about like where are
they going to make money from elsewhere
um and on the other hand like they
probably shouldn't be day trading and so
like how do you come up with the rule
set I don't know what do you think I
think uh immediate disclosure would
would solve a lot of issues because now
you've got you know Nancy Pelosi makes a
trade she's got a 45-day window to
disclose it a lot of changes in 45 days
especially in the stock or options
Market but even beyond that there are
exemptions to where you can extend that
45 days to sometimes 90 days or 120 days
and it's remarkable because if we just
had immediate disclosure for me I'd
think go ahead let everybody trade you
know go ahead you want to buy or sell
but it's just instantly available then
uh then at least people can spot Trends
or investigative journalists could go oh
okay they just had a committee meeting
Nancy Pelosi literally just walked out
of that committee meeting in 20 minutes
after the meeting she went and bought
this stock or whatever okay you know
that that I think would be very useful
full for the public but now it's like
okay well what meeting did you walk out
of you know when you traded well we have
no idea because that was 45 days ago
right so and as you continue to watch uh
kind of the markets play out you have
the content business you have uh uh the
real estate business that you're
building you have the ETFs is there
anything else that really that you're
doing or this those three things and
you're kind of using the distribution
and audience to drive the businesses
yeah I mean those are the three core
things and the ETFs I've really launched
those initially I've launched them just
to be attacks tool for me so that way if
a stock runs I can sell it without
having to pay capital gain sizes the
last thing I want to do is pay more
taxes so the ETFs they're expensive to
launch but I I think it's worth it uh is
probably three to 400k a year and that's
every year just to just to manage these
things and what how much assets do you
have to get into the fund for you to
kind of break even well this would be
this would make sense for me well it
makes sense for for me just right away
like I don't really care if anybody else
invested or not people are like I'm
assure your ETS like I don't care do
whatever you want uh so but if we wanted
to break even from a business point of
view on the ETFs probably need 20 to 30
mil under management of those I I don't
foresee that happening anytime soon I
mean maybe if they do really well
that'll happen but that's not the goal
my primary and so that's to me like a
little Sideshow it's a little tax
strategy it's it's not terribly
important but I had to get licensed to
do that there's a lot of compliance that
comes with that and it's fine with me we
could handle it the and you have a team
that works on that oh well or is it just
you it's Mo for the ETFs it's mostly
going to be me although we're gonna have
uh two more series 65 licensees so it
will be a very small team but uh and
they're like running operations or
they're more on the investment side well
we so for the operating the ETF we can
Outsource that that's part of the three
to four hundred K but uh we need series
65 licensees who can do research and
compliance those are the most important
things so it would be a very small team
but research and compliance are the big
deals yeah it and on this I'm fascinated
by this idea that uh people using the
internet can Now launch these businesses
like there are not many people in the uh
professional Financial Services business
who would say oh you can create an asset
management firm essentially with three
people and have ETFs and kind of do all
this stuff how much of that is driven
just by your thought process of how to
build something and like you want to be
more efficient and kind of a strategy
versus there's Technology Innovation
that's happened in the last decade or so
where you're like okay now this is
actually possible because Technology's
changed oh it's both it's both yeah I
mean look at it this way with um
house hack my uh househack.com not a
solicitation read the PPM there there's
all the compliance stuff you have to do
now uh with househack which is a
regulation D fundraise that we're doing
we've raised now 27 million in in 21
days which is remarkable yeah we were
and that's at the bottom of the market
we were worried like what if we only get
like 400k in the first you know month
that's terrible it's like shut the doors
forget it how does it work like what
what is the idea behind house hack oh
yeah
um so we're gonna buy single family
multi-family deals that are fixer-uppers
we'll rent them out short term and
long-term rentals in maybe three markets
Diversified through the United States
and we'll grow it we but this is uh
people who are investing they're
investing in a fund or they're investing
in the equity yeah oh they're getting
shares of the company so the way it
works is we're actually selling founder
shares because my look no I've never
done a fund before or a fundraise like
this so nobody knows meet Kevin and
fundraising so the my thought is okay
give folks founder shares because I want
those people to be so well rewarded when
if we IPO in the future because that
just establishes and cements my
reputation as like oh well that's what
you did before and look what it turned
into right this is going to take a lot
of work but uh I'm paying my whole
reputation on it and so if we raise 100
million dollars the company's valuation
is going to be 100 million dollars so if
somebody invests a million dollars
they'll have one percent ownership of
the company no obviously like in the
future after IPO they'll always be stock
based comp and things like that but as
with any company
so uh but anyway
we're going back to your efficiency
question I'll just give you an example
when I first started the fund uh raise
for this company we were told okay we're
going to need a team of people who can
man the phones we're gonna need you know
people who can take the subscription
agreements and and take people's
information do they want to own it in an
LLC a trust and then we'll prepare the
documents then we'll send the documents
to them after we verify that they're
accredited investors and and I was just
so overwhelmed with all these steps that
they wanted people to go through I
thought no no no here's here's the way
me Kevin's going to do it first of all
we're not doing any phone calls second
of all we're not doing any sales
I'm the sales guy and we're gonna do it
through live streams third of all I am
paying anybody's wire fees so people are
like oh well like if people wire in 25
Grand like they're you're gonna have a
receiving fee of 15 I'm like no we're
not the investor is going to pay that
otherwise they're going to get 15 less
of shares and the reason for that is if
I have 2 000 people wire me money that's
30 grand and that's an entire year of
rental property income for a property
that we own cash right without even
considering expense I'm like no no we we
can streamline things and people can pay
them 15 while keeping expenses low
expenses is what kills businesses
employees and employee costs kill
businesses so no we're not having any
man phones Kevin will sell it have a
question email it post on Discord or
wait for the next q a live stream easy I
think the best person to sell is me
so uh those were areas where we really
thought we could scale but also
technology that we have now is is not
even that impressive but it's just like
DocuSign it's electronically signing
stuff everybody's done that already
before but we can now do conditional
forms where people click okay I want to
invest as an LLC okay Boop now it fills
in okay now you have to fill out uh the
name of the LLC or the date of the trust
or the name of your retirement custodian
like those forms pop up when you click a
certain button so now we don't have to
do it right it's all automated so uh
people can literally is this how easy we
wanted to make it people can literally
go to househack.com
click apply
upload their W-2s to prove that they're
accredited
uh take a picture of their driver's
license sign the agreement and go to the
bank and wire money all within 30
minutes and I could have money show up
before I've ever even opened their
document to counter sign it no it sits
in escrow until we counter sign it and
verify but it's easy enough if I open it
up it's signed I look and I go W-2
social driver's license names they all
match up the incomes are such that
you've made over 200 000 on average the
last two years you're an individual
investor okay I hit sign done so I could
spend three minutes doing that entire
process on one person and they could
send fifty thousand dollars uh and pay
their own Wi-Fi right but that's just an
example of how
social media
is allowing us to raise money without
advertising technology is allowing us to
sell the fund without
sales people on the phone uh and we can
streamline these processes to to create
a company at very low cost and I think
that's the future yeah talk a little bit
about uh actually fundraising to the
public right because I think there's
some people who are like this is amazing
it's going to democratize access all
this stuff but you also talked about the
accreditation laws and the fact that
they still need to meet certain criteria
I'm guessing but don't want to assume
that you would like to see those changed
if uh if possible but unfortunately
that's just the way the rules are today
uh and so how do you think about this
like new way of fundraising where you
can use something like a YouTube channel
or whatever to go directly to people
yeah well that means is incredible
because it just lowers the startup costs
for businesses which is actually better
for businesses I want to invest in
businesses that have low expenses like
people here oh Tesla's laying off a
bunch of you know office staff uh most
people are like oh they must be
suffering I'm like oh margin that's
really evil because people are losing
their jobs right it's like totally
terrible but so like from a humanitarian
point of view I'm like that sucks like
now they're out of a job from a business
point of view I'm like that's great
right and that's that's just capitalism
that's the way it is uh as far as the
accreditation laws it's tough because
they're there for a reason and people
get really mad about that they're like
oh this is only for the one percent well
that's the SEC has established those
rules for a reason because most people
shouldn't be investing in private Equity
because they don't realize they could
lose 100 of their money uh so that's
really important and they have to have
that capability so I mean I've invested
in Venture Capital before and I've lost
a lot of money investing in Venture
Capital before but that's okay it's just
like that was the risk I took going into
business knowing that like I could lose
all of this so you write that check it
could all go away but I don't even think
about it anymore because it didn't
change my life it was just a little
number in an account whatever that's the
way it works that's very different for
somebody who's got a net worth that's
ten thousand dollars and they invest 10
of their net worth thousand dollars into
something and they lose all of that
that's that's huge that's would it be
better if it was percentage like so sure
rather than say Hey you have to make two
hundred thousand dollars you know every
year or whatever or have a million
dollar net worth uh and then you can
just invest whatever you want I always
joke like I know a lot of dumb smart uh
dumb rich people yeah right oh that's
true yeah oh yeah and so uh it still
allows you to go like Max Bid And so you
make 200 000 and you just take all 200
000 and just invest it right uh then
then maybe that's not the greatest thing
either but if there was some sort of
percentage basis where it was like Hey
look you can't uh I don't know you can't
invest any more than one year's income
50 of one year's income in a single
investment right uh unless you meet some
criteria uh or the other thing is like
just have them take the test like just
literally create a test if you have the
information I don't give a [ __ ] how much
money you make right like you have the
information you're a big boy or girl
like go knock yourself out and see what
happens
um but it just feels like uh the whole
idea of like we've written uh the rich
get richer yes right into law like you
know when people talk about this but
like there has to be a better way and
it's almost like pick your poison
because there's a couple of different
ways you could do it just what do they
want to do where they feel like uh they
can still have oversight over the market
which is you know to your point is
important so they let you uh do a lot of
these things but it's surprising a lot
of people just choose not to eat even go
those Avenues so for example if you're a
series 7 licensee your broker
you can you can you can invest you can
have a net worth of 20K you can invest
your accredited investor so like you can
pass the test and what's remarkable is
two months uh two or three months before
I started a house hack and started we
started raising money I said hey if you
go past the test you can invest two
people did wow they're like I mean two
people did it is actually the impressive
part the impressive part it's like I'm
actually impressed that two people
actually did they went out of their way
to get their tests so that they could
invest but it also is like okay well
it's only two people so it also is like
see there is an Avenue for you to invest
but uh a very few want to go through
that effort uh if we then do and this is
where it gets scary is like you then do
a regulation a offering we can open up
to you know 100 Investments if we want
and I think the rule there is you can't
invest more than 10 of your net worth
it's like a self-certification thing or
whatever but uh what I found is that
most companies who do right gays and
then they offer initial Investments of a
very low amount like a hundred dollars
that's where all the lawsuits come from
it's like really low amount because
maybe the investors just don't
understand that oh why I know I signed a
thing that said I could lose all my
money but I didn't actually think you
meant that right uh so one of the things
we're thinking of is okay well we're
going to go in that regulation a route
we'll open it up to non-accredited
investors maybe in January but we're
actually thinking about setting the
minimum threshold up say a fifteen
thousand dollar investment so that way
theoretically they'd have to certify
that their net worth is at least 150k so
even though we could take as little as a
hundred dollars we don't know if we want
that because that just opens up
liability uh you know not that we expect
to to do anything wrong like we're gonna
have audited financials for a reggae all
of our financials will be transparent
like here's the money or our expenses oh
wait there are very few expenses because
we're not even operating it we're not
even buying real estate yet because
we're waiting for the market but still
you can open yourself up to risk and the
lower you go just the more you open
yourself up to liability so as a retail
investor who might be watching and
they're like you know I have a 50 000
net worth I'd love to put a thousand
dollars in it's just unfortunately you
statistically are more likely to file a
lawsuit than someone who's got two
million dollars to invest so a lot of
businesses shy away from that do you
spend a lot of your time thinking about
risk and kind of how to mitigate it and
part of it is like you live at this
intersection of the content so very
public and uh I joke all the time that
uh there's not a lot of billionaires
watching YouTube some of them do but uh
for the most part the people in the
audience no matter how sophisticated
they are or whatever just naturally uh
aren't billionaires because there's not
that many in the world uh and YouTube I
think has two billion monthly actives so
yeah yeah there's a mismatch of numbers
uh but the second thing then is the
financial industry where there's heavy
regulation and kind of laws and all
these things like do you how do you
think about risk and have you ever
wanted to do something it was legal and
you thought it was a good idea but you
decided not to do it because of uh risk
mitigation today's episode is brought to
you by ftxus there are safe regulated
way to buy Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
they've got very cheap fees sometimes as
much as 85 percent cheaper than their
competitors there's also no minimum fees
there's no withdrawal fees or any other
hidden fees ultimately FTX us is trying
to make it dead simple for you to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they also
now have digital stock trading as well
with no transaction fees and no payment
for order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code Pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today no I I'm
always a fan of do it yeah and the
reason for that is I have this belief
that the as much as we might hate the
rules and laws they're probably there
for a reason so for example I have read
the entire security Exchange Commission
regulation on investment advisors
advertising rules the entire thing
multiple times
and
there's one section for example that a
lot of people screw up on all the time
and it's that hey here's a testimonial
look they really like my ETF come buy it
the SEC wants you to say was that person
paid to make that disclosure is that
person going to benefit from your you
know promotion of them as a testimonial
or will you benefit from from them and
are they somehow you know affiliated
with your business that to me sounds
natural like I should say hey by the way
you know this person has an ownership
interest in my ETF business they're
making a testimonial by the way this is
their feedback we think it's non-biased
but this is what they're saying here's a
person who is not paid to make a
testimony this is what they said I don't
think that's a terrible thing it's a
compliance headache because now you have
to go through and okay if you're doing
testimonials which could be as simple as
a YouTube comment a YouTube comment
somebody could leave oh I've made so
much money on your ETF and if you heart
it that's a compliance nightmare because
now that becomes a testimonial that
you've endorsed YouTube sorts it a
little higher big headache you could get
in trouble for doing that because you
didn't disclose hey you know do they
have ownership Pinterest do they have a
conflict of interest or whatever but
when I look at the actual Merit of the
law I'm like
I mean to protect investors that makes
sense you know or for example they say
another rule is hey if you talk about
performance of your ETF you have to
provide net performance as in net of
fees so if you have outperformed the s p
but your fees are two percent and now
you've actually underperformed the S P
500 well the investor deserves to know
that I actually think that's a good
thing uh so I I'm actually all for those
sort of transparents I do feel like the
transparency stuff uh you're
hard-pressed to find people who don't
like them uh other than uh operations
teams compliance team that's the head
cost right uh but to some degree like
that's the cost of doing business
exactly yeah yeah that's that's the big
thing is like it's now you have to hire
somebody who's a compliance person and
nobody likes the compliance person
because the compliance person I know you
said that wrong you have to delete the
Tweet or you ever repost it or whatever
right uh and uh so they have a miserable
job in my opinion yeah talk to them
about house hacking uh you mentioned
earlier if you bought all the real
estate uh cash yeah is that what the
plan is or are you are you going to
finance any of it eventually So the plan
is
so let's say we just to make math easy I
don't I don't know if we'll get there
but that'd be great but we'll see let's
say we raised 100 million dollars
we can now go buy real estate we don't
need to finance it day one because we
have all this cash we may as well have
it it's either sitting the bank or it's
enrolling you know six month treasuries
or it's in real estate may as well
deploy it in real estate is Cash first
of all we can get better deals and
second of all we're shielded from higher
interest rates for longer because we
think prices will bottom
uh when the FED u-turns but it'll take a
while for mortgage rates to actually
fall so if mortgage rates are seven
percent right now we don't want to pay
seven percent on a mortgage they'll go
back to three percent in the future so
buy prices low cash negotiate better
deals when we're at more Peak fear in
the market and then when rates are maybe
back down to four percent well then we
can start refinancing after we've
deployed the capital so the thesis is
a lot of startups fail because they
create a new product and then there's
not enough demand for that product and
they don't have money that comes in they
have high payrolls and then they go
bankrupt because they're not selling and
they have high costs the cool thing
about real estate is this is not like a
secret product that we don't know how
the Market's gonna like it this is you
buy a house you rent it out cash flow
comes in if you buy cash you cash flow
now you just need you know your first 30
or 40 homes or so to cover all the
payroll for the operating company or
property managers your acquisition team
your accountants after that it's just
pure cash flow and so our goal is to
build this really strong Foundation of
if we have 100 Mil we spend 100 Mil and
three different Diversified markets now
we cash flow now we look and say okay
what if we refinance 25 of the portfolio
took out 70 of those use that money go
buy more properties now maybe refinance
the next 25 I mean we could do this for
the next five years we will if we raised
100 million dollars we and then we could
end up having you know certainly uh
somewhere to get to a billion dollars of
real estate with 100 million dollars
raised probably not uh you know if we
got really good deals had great cash
flow maybe we could get to 500 uh with
with 100 raise which is no different
than if you had 100 million sitting
there and you wanted to go buy 500
million dollars real estate put 20 down
you get the financing right kind of
backs into similar yeah and I would say
you could do it that way I was thinking
more like uh 35
uh and so leaving a little bit more in
that way you have more cash flow a
little bit more margin of safety and uh
and then getting good deals to kind of
get you there yeah but yes yeah
somewhere around 350 you get good deals
they appreciate a little bit because you
bottom right at the bottom of the market
sure will it grow to 1 billion hopefully
at some point in the future right how do
you think about risk for this business
specifically like what are the big risks
that you guys have identified we were
like hey this is how we screw this up uh
it's it's all any business it's always
payroll it's keeping payroll low is so
important so what we don't want to do is
have like a massive construction team
that's running around every time a light
fixture breaks you've got to have really
good people who can coordinate
subcontractors really well and that's
key uh so I have
uh four people that are full-time
construction workers for me personally
outside of this company and they're
working on my Renovations they do all my
own Renovations and the Beautiful Thing
is we've got two Renovations that are
probably going to take them about six or
seven months large projects we're
turning like a three unit building into
a six unit building a one unit into
three so on and so forth this will keep
them busy for the next six months but
what's great is they know my formula
they know exactly what I want they know
how to do the job they know what I
complain about and so the more they work
for me the more the more educated they
get and sort of refining how they work
they've been working some of them have
been working with me since 2017. and
what's neat is when those projects are
done and we start buying for house hack
they're not going to be swinging the
hammer anymore they're now going to take
everything that they've perfected there
and just coordinate uh subcontractors
electricians plumbers concrete whatever
flooring companies in our different
markets and so I already have those
people I don't have that risk of now I
gotta find people who can coordinate and
learn my model I already have them I
just move them over from my personal
payroll to the house hack payroll when
we're ready for them which is great
because it's kind of like having a
reservation on a really good employee
but paying no money for them while we
don't need them so I'm very excited
about that but yeah at some point in the
future expanding you know hiring more
employees in different areas and this is
where yeah I got to be really careful
that we don't expand into too many
different markets because then you're
not an expert in all those markets I
grew up in Broward County Florida that's
an easy market for me I live in Ventura
County California that's an easy market
for me I start expanding into you know a
third fourth Market okay I can handle
that but if we start talking about five
six seven eight that's where it gets
scarier because now it's like okay now I
gotta be really careful so that's where
the risk comes how do you pick the third
and fourth market like what are the
things you look at to say like this is a
good Market to actually go into yeah
absolutely so uh the first key is is
poverty the poverty rate's got to be low
we certainly don't want to be investing
in areas where the poverty rate is is
anywhere above 13 14
uh we want to be in those markets where
the poverty rate's between nine and
twelve percent we want population growth
and median income growth population
growth can be flat but median income
would have to be going up so there's a
little caveat there that means poorer
people are leaving and wealthy people
are coming in or it's just leaving the
wealthier people we want to rent to
Middle to upper class individuals people
who have white-collar jobs 700 Plus
credit scores and you know I I get a lot
of flack for that people are like why oh
my gosh I can't believe you you wouldn't
rent to somebody with less than a 700
credit score we don't want risk this
business will fail if we let risk
controls run away so we want people who
have steady incomes this is why like
when you say why is it that the SEC
requires like a 200 000 income for an
accredited investor well because they
can turn around and even if they get
fired they can get another job for 180
000 and they can survive right uh and so
the same is true of somebody frequently
with a 700 Plus credit score is that
they uh even if they have hardship they
can figure out how to get through it if
somebody has a 550 credit score they
lose their job and they have some debts
just go bankrupt stop who cares like
your credit score is not going to get
any worse you have no leverage uh
against the tenant so mitigating that
the those very important so we want to
be in
uh
the markets that I've described upper to
middle middle to upper middle class and
ideally price points between 400 to 800k
for a fixer-upper
if we're closer to beaches we can Airbnb
if we're closer Inland then we'll
long-term rents so and we'll want to be
in areas like the Cleveland Clinic or
west in Weston where we have
professionals and nurses and doctors
that can rent that's what we're looking
for
the short-term rental business uh has
become very popular it's become popular
with professional investors it's become
popular with uh Tick Tock influencers
the whole thing how do you evaluate when
uh outside of just location is the right
time to short-term rent versus long-term
rent and is it a economic argument of
like hey we can make more money but
there's more headache or how do you kind
of evaluate it oh yeah it's all just the
numbers so you've got to figure there's
a lot more intensity of a short-term
rental than a long-term rental our
typical long-term rentals we talked to
the tenant once a year hey 30-day notice
it's lease renewal time oh yeah okay
cool send me the lease renewal done and
you're like there's nothing to do on
long-term rentals and that's frequently
because we buy fixer-uppers we renovate
them we we think we do a very good job
to where the tenants don't complain
about anything because everything's new
you know like there's nothing to
complain about
so uh long-term pressure managing those
properties oh yeah or they have other
you all internal management okay yeah
and it will continue and always be
internal management because a lot of
term rentals are easy in our opinion uh
so we don't see a reason to pay for
those fees where
it gets expensive to manage properties
in short-term rentals because you're
constantly you need a concierge service
that can answer the phone some cities
require you have a 24-hour hotline that
somebody can call in order to get your
short-term short-term rental license a
lot of short-term rentals suck because
it's a landlord who has one or two
properties they don't have that 24-hour
service they don't have the connections
to to vendors to get problem solved
quickly they don't or they cheap out on
things or whatever I think there's a
huge opportunity to really
improve on the existing short-term
rental space but the to answer your
question we have to look at hey if we
can rent a property out for three
thousand dollars a month long term have
no headache and virtually no employee
costs you know where one employee can
manage 200 single families because
there's like no work to do and that's
their full-time job you know one
employee could probably only manage
you know fourth as many or even less
short-term rentals because it's so much
more intensive
so at what point does that make sense is
it okay long-term rental three thousand
dollars a month short-term rental is 3
500 a month probably doesn't make sense
short-term rental is six thousand
dollars a month of income okay yeah now
now we've got margin that's where we can
play with it so those are the kind of
markets we want to look at I mean I just
looked at
I just went through a neighborhood where
I'm like I would never buy a long-term
rental here it's just not the kind of
tenant we're looking for uh I I don't
even want to be here like I don't even
feel good about being here right now and
uh and then I'm looking at the Airbnb
competition uh I'm looking at this three
unit building and I look at the airbnbs
and I'm like well if I long term rented
this I could get
twenty five hundred dollars in long-term
rent for the whole building then I look
at Airbnb because it's so close to the
beach I'm like I could get eight
thousand six hundred dollars a month for
this building this is insane and how do
you calculate that like do you just
calculate some sort of uh um occupancy
rate you know on a per like what is the
rate that you normally use is it half
the month a third of the month the full
month so it it depends on the area
usually uh the areas I was looking at
today they'll go with 65 to 70 occupancy
and you could use you know matrices
online like air DNA or whatever they
give you these average uh occupancy
rates uh I like to be conservative and I
go with half most of the time just half
the month is the Assumption of 15 days
out of the the month uh because you have
seasonality as well some seasons are
going to be a lot busier some are going
to be a lot slower so I think half is a
good safety net to go with and what I
like to do is I just like to look at all
the competition go okay what's a one
bedroom renting out for okay well if
that one bedroom is renting for 150
bucks I'll just run my numbers at 120.
but I'll undercut the competition 20 or
whatever and if the numbers make sense
there
glaringly well then it could really only
be better yeah if if we get more so that
makes sense
um talking about Bitcoin and crypto like
you I think weren't into it then you
were into it then you weren't into it
are you back into it like where do you
stand how do you look at it yeah yeah
it's so what's crazy is I
um boy I messed up I uh I've been making
videos for like two years about how I I
thought that stable coins were were
dangerous and so I never invested in
stable coins and so what I thought was
the safer option was investing into uh
the the companies like Voyager right uh
and so what's remarkable is the things I
even had interviews the the CEOs of of
block fi and Voyager and I would ask
them about tell me about the stable coin
risks right because I was so worried
about stable coins I'm like were we
worried about stable coins rates of
return are not sustainable you can't get
80 or eight percent annualized Returns
on on you know an asset that's as good
as cash in theory unless it's actually
not as good as cash it's just
re-hypothecated you know four or five
times down the road or more and there's
no transparency we like to think that
crypto is very transparent but it's no
transparency and how often these are
re-hypothecated there's just no
regulation around that whereas at least
with the banks because we know they're
rehypothecating as well we can do stress
tests and we know uh credit suite's
about to go under you know we could we
could see oh credit default swaps were
getting really expensive on Credit
Suisse we got some problems here right
so we can see those things
with stable coins you can't there's no
uh there's no pricing or or Market risk
adjustment for what the valuation of
these is because they're in theory
pegged to a dollar money for the stable
coins
so uh that has always been a fear for me
and so I stayed away from those and
instead invested in you know companies
directly whether it's block fly or
Voyage or whatever you know turns out
it's actually those companies that end
up getting whacked when stable coins
break so when Terra Luna collapsed uh
thanks to the three arrows Capital
collapse which led Voyager digital to
bankruptcy I got screwed you know and
block fight to its knees and so on so
forth so I got screwed on on some of
those Investments but that's that's my
fault you know so I'm a big boy I'm like
all right well that's that's the way it
works so as much as I was warning about
that
I ended up I still ended up on the wrong
side of the trade oh well happens uh but
as far as
yeah Bitcoin ethereum uh I'm uh you know
if I had to choose I'm a probably the
biggest proponent of Bitcoin I'm not I'm
worried that once the ethereum lockups
occur we're going to actually really see
a crash in ethereum and the reason for
that is I think there are a lot of uh
companies in the crypto space that have
a lot of their money tied up into
ethereum's lockup the 2.0 lockup now
that the merge has occurred and we know
they're going to start phasing out the
lockups over you know six months and
after I worry that there's going to be a
lot of liquidity demand so a lot of
selling pressure and that's no different
than a company going public all of a
sudden that stock six months and one day
later gets handed to the investors many
of them is just their mandate is to sell
it some of them are like hey I've held
this for five six ten twelve years I'm
selling uh and so naturally when those
lock up uh expire usually there is some
depression in price uh generally because
of the the market dynamics you think is
similar here absolutely absolutely so if
I was going to pick it'd probably be a
Focus right now on on bitcoin but again
that's where I have to evaluate well do
I want the companies that at inexpensive
valuations right now or Bitcoin and so
my choice right now is stocks because I
think there's some very attractive
valuations and companies that can get
through the earnings recession see if
the stock market Falls because of an
earnings recession in aggregate the S P
500 boosts down another 10 percent
crypto's probably gonna go with it
they're I think they're on the same ride
so if I can hide in companies hopefully
like Tesla that uh survive that earnings
recession that's just the best thesis I
have right now although I've been wrong
in the past I'll be wrong again in the
future just hopefully not this time but
we'll see well I'm laughing to myself
because uh I think you've articulated
the Tesla thesis but I know when people
hear like hide in Tesla there's some
people who are like oh what the [ __ ] is
this guy talking about right sure uh but
but I think that's how markets get made
right is uh you have a thesis you are
allocating money you're taking risk in
the market somebody's on the other side
uh and some people write something to be
wrong and like that's kind of the beauty
of capitals this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine I sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep it really is
uh it's put your money where your mouth
is you know if that's what you believe
then do it you know I there are a lot of
people who say oh a Tesla's valuation is
so stupid and it's fine if you look at
the last 12 months trailing PE it's
terrible you know you're paying like 180
times earnings if you now look at
something like the forward PE ratio it's
like oh 4p ratio is actually only like
49 right now and their growth rate is 50
to 60 percent of earnings their earnings
growth rate is 50 to 60 that means we're
potentially looking at a company that
has a PEG ratio of under one well gee
you know snap has a PEG ratio of five
apple has a PEG ratio I I I want to say
right now of somewhere actually I mean
it could be closer to three and so you
have companies that when we value them
based on their earnings growth rate or
actually they seem like a good
opportunity but then they're very
expensive so it all depends on how do
you value companies what do you actually
think the growth rate is going to be if
somebody is listening and they think
well I don't think Tesla's going to be
able to sell all their cars you know
their growth rates can plummet then
obviously Tesla's a horrible investment
if you think Tesla is going to be able
to continue to sell their cars and all
they have to do is manufacture more of
them then I think they're going to be a
great investment over the next two years
but like you said
the market is an opportunity for you to
make a choice and allocate that way and
you're either gonna be a writer you'll
be wrong I think a lot about uh a thesis
is actually made up of a bunch of sub
thesis right yeah and so your idea of
like hey I'm going to allocate to Tesla
because I think they're going to survive
the uh kind of earnings recession as you
described it is really predicated on the
fact that uh one Tesla is going to
continue to make cars at some rate that
is uh attractive two is that the demand
for Tesla cars is not going to uh ever
be uh inferior to the number of course
they are producing and therefore they'll
always be able to sell all of their cars
at full price without discounts like
there's all these little components to
it and I think part of uh what's
exciting and intellectually stimulating
about investing is that like there's a
lot of analysis there right and you've
got to kind of think through this stuff
the part that makes investing hard is
you really only need like one thing to
go wrong in that entire equation and
it's like oh by the way Tesla's only
going to produce 50 of the cars that
they thought they were going to uh
produce yeah that'd be a major problem
and so it's a the complex machine just
one company and then you kind of
compound it with looking at a bunch of
companies the entire economy and it
comes back to this idea of like I don't
think that there's a lot of really young
people who don't have experience that
understand how complex and hard this
stuff is it's remarkable I mean you know
one of the things that I try to do on a
daily basis is I try to read earnings
calls on a daily basis and so the the
Nuance gets so extreme that three months
ago I looked at Carnival Cruise Lines
I'm like oh these seem cheap let's go to
the earnings call because the CEOs will
leave hints but they'll try to dress up
those hints right so you look at
Carnival Cruise Lines three months ago
and they're like yeah you know our
demand is going back up from 2021 well
sure it is every travel industry is
going up from 2021 but what are you
saying about you know demand going
forward well we're we're working on
advertising in in a new way and so we're
going to do this new advertising
strategy and we're going to double down
we're going to spend a lot more money on
advertising and so that was sending a
signal to me that like wait a minute
so you're saying things are getting so
much better but not only are you saying
now we're going to advertise a lot more
but you're also saying and we're going
to try this new advertising strategy so
what you're telling me is the old
advertising strategy is not working so
now you want me to take a gamble on your
new advertising strategy and you need to
advertise because you don't see enough
organic demand keeping you so you have
to advertise you're increasing costs
with the hope that you're going to get
increased Revenue in a positive manner
but if for some reason you increase your
cost and don't get the increase in
Revenue then you're screwed yeah
especially since you're doing it in a
new manner like this new advertising
it's like well what what if you suck at
advertising advertising is hard
so I'm like yeah no thanks and uh they
just had their last earnings report and
they fell like 25
and in it they're like
we're still gonna double down on
advertising and our new strategy hasn't
worked yet but still and I'm like this
is terrible right and and they're so
indebted and that's the other factor
that went into Carnival they're so in
debt is I want to say if I were off the
top of my head they're paying over a
million dollars a day in interest which
is insane because I think they're
quarterly uh uh net I I'll butcher these
numbers but I think they're quarterly
net in 2019 with somewhere around like
300 million dollars and the way the math
worked out it was somewhere around a
third to forty percent of what their
quarterly net used to be is now going to
debt because they didn't used to have as
much High interest rate debt now they're
spending it all
uh on debt and they're losing money hand
over fists I'm like this is a terrible
industry to be in right now so
the point of all of that is not to turn
this podcast into a Carnival Cruise
Lines analysis is to say you're right
there's so much you could look at I mean
you could look at uh going back to Tesla
this idea that okay well what if
consumers stop buying and we we do end
up seeing that drop in demand well then
there's this counter thesis that no
problem Hertz will come in and buy them
you know it's it's insane maybe maybe
exactly but then what if people are
traveling less because consumer demand
is going down it hurts like yeah never
mind on those contracts right
it's exhausting but I love it what about
stock BuyBacks like there's one argument
of hey these companies are all idiot
Capital allocators they're wasting all
their money on stock BuyBacks uh covid
hits and in March of 2020 they go
running to the government for bailouts
of the airline industry and they spent
the last decade doing stock 5x on the
other hand it's like no actually stock
BuyBacks are just a tax efficient way to
return value to shareholders
um then you overlay that with the
complexity of like the executive teams
are actually compensated via stock price
milestones and so are they actually
making bad Capital allocation decisions
to drive the stock price up which should
help shareholders but really it's just
so they get paid more money like it's
not a simple topic uh but how do you
evaluate what you're seeing now around
stock BuyBacks and maybe how that's
changed over the last couple of months
yeah that's really it's first of all
very politically touchy because you're
right it's like oh they're just trying
to prop up their stock price so I'm
going to try to look at it from a a
bottom-up approach here and I'm gonna
put myself in the shoes via of let's say
a CEO via house hack and so here's a
thesis is that I have my thesis with
househack is that we're going to buy
homes below market value is that's the
plan hopefully so let's say we buy a 400
000 fixer upper it needs fifty thousand
dollars of work we're in it for 450.
it's in a 600k neighborhood we got that
property at a discount great we're gonna
put that aside
now let's say we're a public company and
we bought this property for a discount
and now all of a sudden let's say
instead of trading for two or three
times Book value like a lot of real
estate companies do let's say there's
some kind of real estate crash or or
market crash in the stock market and
we're like Lennar Homes the second
largest homebuilder and they're actually
selling for 90 cents on the dollar right
they're selling for less than Book value
right now well if I'm a CEO of let's say
house hack in this case and I'm looking
at my stock I'm like we're selling for
90 cents on the dollar I know those
properties or quality properties I know
what those assets are worth I would be
an idiot not to buy our own stock back
because now I'm actually able to do the
same thing that I did on that single
house where I'm buying a house for less
than it's worth in a neighborhood I'm
doing the same thing with a stock that I
know what the value is because I'm
running the company I know the assets of
it I know it more than probably anybody
else
so I think stock BuyBacks completely
makes sense in that example now where it
gets complicated is what you said well
what if now you're getting compensated
on on uh you know stock options or
whatever well yeah then then you have
some political implications and I think
that's why the Biden Administration is
now trying to tax stock BuyBacks so
we're gonna do a one percent tax on
BuyBacks or whatever
um yeah I think there's a balance I
think there's a balance there where
where you can have some tax where you're
able to use that money to help people
who are not in markets because the
people who made the most money during
the pandemic weren't poor people it was
businesses getting bailed out it was
real estate getting bailed out and it
was stock owners getting developed they
made the most money so
um yeah there's there's an element of
fairness there and there's I think a
reasonable argument for some taxation
what's the one thing in financial
markets right now that you think is
really really important but you feel
like other people aren't talking about
or aren't paying attention to is there
something that you're like I know like I
would yell it from the rooftop people
would listen buy a home it's buy a home
there's there's so much anti by a home
and I don't think now is the best time I
think you can wait a year or so but but
that should be everybody's goal is by
home and unfortunately there there are
so many uh people who argue no always
ran never buy
um and and there's this financial wisdom
some say of only buy a home cash or wait
until you have 25 to buy a home never
buy a home with three percent down or
five percent I think a lot of those
things are really misplaced because if
you get a good deal with five percent
down it could be like you're getting it
for 20 down because you got a good deal
but the problem is most people will save
money
here I'll I'll reveal something well
I've talked about this before so it's
not gonna be a secret to everybody but
it might be a surprise to some
I love overdrafting my bank account
and I what yeah I absolutely love it
when my wife sends me a text and goes
hey we just got over drafted on our bank
account because it makes us both feel
poor and so we want to spend less money
now as long as you you I love does this
happen often
uh not the not so much this year but
last year it probably happened I don't
know like eight or nine times uh and I
never got charged with an overdraft fee
because I would just like okay all right
I'll transfer some money in right uh but
I want to keep the accounts as low as
possible because I put them all into
Investments and to me the Investments
are the emergency fund I can always go
to my stock broker like I could go to my
stock brokerage account and I could have
you know 10 million dollars of margin
zero uh outstanding balance on it and a
million dollars of cash sitting there
but my personal account has like twenty
thousand dollars so we pay off a credit
card with thirty thousand dollars in
expenses uh oops it auto paid it's
upside down or whatever okay we gotta
quickly transfer it
that always keeps me awake to this idea
of okay we have to manage expenses we
have to make sure we're not paying
overdraft fees right I think people hear
overdraft I think you're paying the fee
but as long as you put the money in the
same day you're fine uh and we do but it
makes us feel like no we got to watch
our money right no matter how much money
you have you have to watch the dollars
and your expenses because for most
people going back to that house thing if
you're like all right I'm Gonna Save up
25 for a home they put it all in their
savings or checking account or whatever
every day they open up their bank
account they're like ah I got a hundred
thousand dollars now now they're looser
at dinner they buy that bottle of wine
they they buy that new jacket for four
thousand dollars whatever and they're
looser because they see it there I open
up I see red and I'm like
we ain't buying a four thousand dollar
jacket you know so like even though I
know I have the money to buy it
psychologically it I I prefer feeling
tight like no no it's allocated because
it's very painful to go into your stock
brokerage and take money out of there to
go spend it on a jacket uh it's it's a
lot easier to spend four thousand
dollars if it's sitting in a savings
account because you just swipe your
debit card or whatever hopefully you're
not using a debit card but whatever uh
it's a lot easier to do that and so
that's why I think saving up 25 and and
waiting to buy is such terrible advice
because it just lets people feel rich
they get loose they don't feel motivated
to work that's another thing when I
overdraft I'm like I work oh you know I
I thought I was going to be done at five
today you know what I'm gonna make
another video tonight
what are some things that you and your
wife have done money-wise that you feel
like really powerful or conversations
that you've had things that people
should uh consider uh around money and
their significant other
wow well with significant other it's
it's so important to be on the same page
and you know knocking wood I think we we
just lucked into it or what it is and
hopefully it stays that way but we're
both on the same page when it comes to
money it's look we we live we could
easily live in a fancy Posh gated
community or whatever and spend five or
ten million dollars on a home but you
know we live in a it's and it's still
nice when we run but it's like an 800
000 home and we live in a very normal
neighborhood with people who make
between 80 to 100
000 120 000 a year some of them maybe a
little more some a little less and uh we
live in a very normal neighborhood very
our kids play with very normal and we
could easily move to Pacific Palisades
and play with billionaire kids as they
say but we're like no no we're gonna
stay in in Ventura where the incomes are
a little lower and we think that sort of
frugality is really important uh and uh
I'm glad we're on the same page of that
we would rather spend money on travel
than on super flashy houses or cars or
clothing or things like that yeah and
what about your kids like how do you
ensure that they don't end up spoiled
like it's something uh hard I think a
lot of my friends I hear them especially
as kids get more aware uh kind of five
to twelve like in that where it's like
oh [ __ ] okay like this is different
right what do you do there
I don't know that I have an answer for
that because now you know I've got a
seven-year-old and four and a half year
old one thing that I think
I I realized this summer is I took them
to Europe and they have no idea the
value of money they're like oh this 80
Lego set I just want it
uh and so what we actually implemented
was this policy that you would earn you
know ten dollars if you were really good
all day like best behavior or whatever
and so if you wanted to buy that Lego at
the end of the week you'd have to earn
it
so we're on vacation so we increase the
allocations a little bit like oh if
you're just really good for dinner you
know you'll get five dollars or whatever
if you did this you'll get a few dollars
and then as soon as they were fussy or
mean or or you know did something mean
to their sibling or or mean to us we
minus that and and so it really made
them realize oh man like it's actually a
little harder to earn this and so that's
something we've tried to carry over now
that we're not on vacation uh back to to
the household we're like okay well if
you want to misbehave it's just money
away you do go down a test you earn
money and so I think helping them see
okay scorecard yeah and there's not this
infinite credit card is good you know I
got a little four and a half year old
he's always like oh Dad how much money
do you have in your bank account and I'm
like I don't like two thousand dollars
and a lot of times it's true because
it's like very close to little uh and uh
and then he's like oh can I have it I go
well here's a bill it's and then I'll
show them like a mortgage statement and
he's like it says two thousand eight
hundred dollars I go yeah exactly and
he's like but you only have two exactly
gotta go to work now yeah it's like oh
dang and really it sounds like you're
doing in kind of a unique way as you're
just reinforcing the idea that like the
money is tied to work yes right and if
they work they can make money and and
kind of grounds them a little bit I
guess I hope so yeah anything else that
you guys do you mentioned earlier that
they don't hang out with billionaires
kids
anything else well uh yeah I mean
gosh what else no I mean not that I
could really think of off the top of my
head I think well okay one thing that
we'll do is this has been useful is we
used to give them their reward
immediately so if they did something
great we would give them their reward
right away which these days it's like
Roblox money
so now what we do is if you earn it on
let's say a Tuesday you have to wait
until Friday the great thing then is we
get leverage oh your mean minus one and
they freak out but then they actually
behave nicer because they're like no I
want to earn that back oh I'll be nice
and then you could earn it back so that
delayed gratification I think is really
important if they feel they can walk up
and say I want 4.99 for Roblox
and you buy it for them right away
that I think is where that spoiling
comes in because that now they get that
instant dopamine connection with okay
money's not an object no problem swipe
the card boom face ID great Bing oh yeah
you get to go spend it right away uh
another thing is our four and a half
year old he'll make a mistake on Robux
and uh or he'll spend his Roblox or
whatever on something he didn't mean to
or he'll get scammed or whatever like I
guess you gotta wait you know uh we're
not here to bail you out we're not your
j-pal
yeah and and uh when they go to school
like do you think that they talk about
money or drinks like I'm fascinated by
uh parents who uh like I talk about
Bitcoin and macro and like all this
stuff and so like naturally uh my wife
or our friends like we'll talk about
some of that same stuff and it's like
you probably picked just things up at
the dinner table or whatever and like
I'm like a four and a half year olds
going to talk about macro yeah right
here but like there is this element of
uh the internet also like there's so
much more information that is available
and they see numbers like they know what
Kanye West made on something or or uh an
athlete or whatever and so it just feels
like somehow money has become uh much
more obvious in our society uh than
maybe it was and it's not that money
wasn't a thing previously it's just that
like now literally a seven-year-old can
use the internet to figure out uh what
the salary of a certain type of job is
right and and I don't know if that
necessarily was it that easy previously
I I certainly don't think so I think
money has gotten a whole lot more
transparent now and and people have
become more comfortable talking about
money my kids certainly it's I I try to
get them to not say it but every time at
school or whatever I hear that they're
talking about their parents and my dad
just YouTube and it's like ah you know
it's like stop so do the people in your
neighborhood know oh yeah yeah well it
doesn't help that last Halloween
I dressed my father-in-law up as Janet
Yellen and I built the Federal Reserve
in front of my house really oh yeah out
of plywood we built the Federal Reserve
and I dressed up as Jerome Powell so I
had wait what yeah yeah last Halloween
you built a replica of the Federal
Reserve outside of your house on plywood
uh you dressed up like Jerome Powell and
your father-in-law dressed up like Janet
Yellen and then we give money away
like real money yes
so we we got about uh four thousand
dollars of two dollar bills uh-huh and
uh we we would go outside and we would
um we would go inflation is transitory
and and make it rain two dollar bills
did people film this oh yeah you can go
on YouTube it says like I don't know if
I'm sure if we typed in like meet Kevin
Halloween or something it would come up
but it's there it actually didn't get
that many views uh relative to other
videos but but yeah yeah
um people at first didn't think it was
real money yeah and they're like is that
is that real they thought it was just
throwing money and I'm like yeah those
are real two dollar bills Panic it's
great how many of the parents were doing
it versus the kids oh yeah the parents
were probably more enthusiastic yeah I
would I would uh think so I was at a a
dinner speaking at two dollar bills and
uh I'm gonna forget the guy saying I
think it's two dollar uh two dollar
Steve maybe uh there's a lawyer who's
like Drake's lawyer a bunch of these
lawyers and stuff and he walks around so
he does hands out two dollar bills and
uh uh I was there
um 40 people or something that is dinner
some guy walks in and was all excited
he's literally just handed out two
dollar bills for everyone I was like
what a calling card right is to be the
guy who walks around probably hundreds
of dollars worth of two dollar bills and
like you meet somebody and just like
here's two dollar bill two dollar bill
like the best freaking value like that
guy's brilliant and and if like if
before every trip I could just go to the
bank and get all the twos they have it's
so great because like you want to let's
say you go to a hotel you want to leave
a tip for for the people who are going
to clean the room uh or or the door
person or the person who helps you with
your bags or whatever
one dollar is too little
for holding the door open or helping
with one bag that's a little Rich okay
like I got that much money okay
two dollars that's like four dollars of
value man yeah but it's two
this is called like the Tipping dollar
yeah it's great I mean two dollars for
tips absolutely the best because oh I've
always wanted one or like oh I'm gonna
give this way like there's so much joy
that comes with the two yeah it's
actually worth more than two dollars but
it only cost me to there's uh there's a
lot of study I mean not a lot but
there's a number of studies that show uh
if you give people the option between
like uh do you want the hundred dollars
or do you want the physical item that
actually is only worth seventy dollars
people usually will pick the item and
they feel more uh joy and emotional
response to the physical item versus the
pure cash cold cash even though it is uh
a lesser value and so same thing with
like giving gifts and like all this type
of stuff is uh whether it's for
sentimental reasons uh or whatever
um it's fascinating because like you're
actually getting 70 value you but it's
something cool or whatever and so you
place some extra value outside of just
the monetary value on it and so two
dollar bills is very similar right the
novelty is almost worth uh a couple
extra dollars oh yeah I mean that's
that's a great way to put it I mean yeah
it I think that almost goes to gift
giving I mean I for example
Elon replied to one of my tweets he's
only ever reply to one and uh one of my
employees printed that out and put it in
a picture frame you know what picture
frames are like five dollars like it
doesn't cost a lot of money to print
something out but
that thought is worth like hundreds of
dollars right whereas if you just handed
me a hundred dollars I would have
forgotten it it certainly wouldn't have
been memorable there'd be it and it
would have cost you a lot more I mean
Theory you gave me a lot more value but
it just that that feeling big deal I
agree what what did uh you tweet and
what did he respond with oh yeah it was
it was something the effect of uh hey it
was about the Twitter deal like hey you
know I mean if if they gave Elon if it
could be proven that Twitter gave Elon
fraudulent information
uh then then Elon will win and so I
quoted some some SEC rules and laws and
Elon replied correct
do you think he's going to be forced to
buy it well because it depends what
comes out I mean there have been some
whistleblowers and that that have come
out you know some things are going in
his way in that direction I think what
will end up happening is there'll be
some kind of a negotiated deal generally
people don't want to take lawsuits to
the end most I would say 99 of lawsuits
come to some form of settlement I don't
think this is going to be an exception
so I think he'll either he'll probably
end up buying it because the penalty the
walk away penalty he would have to pay
would be so high if he negotiated
something with Twitter because the
Twitter board would have to go back to
their shareholders and say well this is
why we only took this as a penalty as
opposed to going all the way through and
trying to get that 54 20. so I think
there'll be a negotiated purchase amount
I think you'll end up buying it just for
a lower amount I think so yeah is that
part of his strategy
oh probably oh yeah I mean think about
it I mean you when he initiated this we
were in no means in this macro
environment that we are in now and even
though he's talked about this potential
for a recession coming it's one thing to
say oh yeah there's a chance of
recession coming and then oh there's a
recession yeah we're in the recession
yeah yeah what do you think the lowest
amount is that he could buy it for uh
well probably 20 billion
you know I'm more familiar with the
share price I think it the share price
is probably around 40 bucks right now I
think he agreed at 54.20 I you know I
think the lowest he could probably get
is like 35 bucks
it's a pretty big discount huge huge
discount yeah but if it weren't for this
potential deal happening Twitter stock
would be like 19 well he probably uh
from uh understanding his humor would
not settle for 35 it would have to be 34
20. exactly yeah or uh you know 35.69
exactly like there would be some element
to it 100 the uh uh just so you guys
didn't forget uh I still have my humor
yeah I love that though I mean I think
that's so important because people get
so serious about everything uh you know
I'll make jokes uh on the channel and
I'll constantly because you know we're
in a recession people are losing their
jobs how could you make fun of them and
it's just all this like hate and I just
always hate on the internet and it's
been worse this year compared to any
before because people are actually
hurting like people are losing money
oh well yeah well you always it's um if
you're joking right I think it's a
little bit uh a little bit different
right you hope but but people how could
you make light of that you know
yeah comedians seem to be the uh the
last remaining people who could say
whatever they want on the internet I
don't know how they I mean like but now
that might be in Jeopardy maybe I mean I
went to a Lisa Lampanelli uh uh show a
few years ago actually it's probably
more like 10 years ago now and uh boy
she could make fun of every race it
didn't matter or or religion it didn't
matter if you were you know from
Afghanistan or you're black or you're
Jewish you can make fun of everybody and
they're clapping and loving it and I was
like oh my gosh that takes skill to pull
that off that's impressive like that
impresses me I think comedians are
actually really really smart like the
good ones you have to be really wise and
like witty absolutely incredible where
can we send people to find you on the
internet outside of YouTube so YouTube
just meet Kevin but where else so
outside would be uh meet Kevin on
Instagram real meet Kevin on Twitter uh
I'm generally take me Kevin on Twitter
there he is he's got like two followers
I think I've emailed Twitter like a
million times to to see like come on he
hasn't logged in since 2014 like this is
ridiculous but you know they they allow
squatting so hey they got to keep those
user numbers up you know but yeah the
Bots are uh uh I'm convinced at least
double digit percentage of the users has
to be it has to be it's even YouTube the
YouTube comments it's so bad Instagram
is bad too yeah oh it's it's yeah it's
true it's just all bad now and people
fall for this stuff and it's very sad
you know when I ran for governor I uh in
California
we got over 700 000 votes was really
good obviously I lost but uh how much
did uh Newsome get
oh Newsome I think was a three or four
mil and the next Contender was like 2.2
so you were like per decently close I
got some numbers you know yeah 6X away
yeah the I the so I was running as a
Democrat against the Democrat and I
consider myself like a JFK Democrat I'm
like right in the middle but
um the Republican was getting most of
the other votes because it was like well
if I'm not gonna vote damn I'll vote for
the Republican but I actually beat him
in San Francisco and what's interesting
is most of the people that were getting
who were investing in my my startup
house hack are addresses from like I
shouldn't say most but a lot of them
were from San Francisco but a lot of the
people are in Tech so it seems like the
tech audience really seems to enjoy my
content but um now I forgot what you had
asked will you will you try to run for
president oh I can't I wasn't born in
America sadly I mean I could always say
I was born in Hawaii
I was born in Germany in Germany yeah
but I was going somewhere with that but
oh people would come up to me very few
but it happened they're like Kevin you
know we want you to be governor and
you've got it you've got to have some
regulation around the spam because I
lost two thousand dollars to a crypto
scammer from the comments and I'm like
no they're like there's and people have
come up to me and shown me uh I'll never
forget this lady she comes up to me in
Bakersfield at this campaign rally we're
doing scrolling through I mean probably
uh months worth of conversation with
this scammer building a relationship
with her making her think that that
person was me taking and she didn't
follow me on Instagram but that person
was taking pictures from my Instagram
story dated that day and sending it to
her she didn't follow me on Instagram
she followed me on YouTube and uh and
and so she thought well it had to be
Kevin
yeah it's terrible we um yeah I've seen
uh very very sophisticated right uh
scams that people have pulled
there was one that we saw uh that
included like fake business cards uh
fake contracts like bad and uh
unfortunately you know uh there's not
much that the individuals can do uh and
then you know law enforcement and I will
try to do the best they can but uh
especially if it's somebody outside the
United States or whatever they're always
out of it yeah it's a pretty tough
situation and it's so easy Now to turn
on a VPN and I mean you could be in
Nigeria browsing from London you know I
mean one click and I'm in London now I'm
in Germany now where do you want to be
with your IP address it's it's almost
impossible to to hunt these folks down
and uh as as transparent as as we know
cryptocurrency is via the blockchain
what's been remarkable is Innovations
like tornado cash which has recently I
think either been shuttered or mostly
shut down but
those make it just impossible uh to to
to trace and it's really incredible on
one hand because it gives so many
so many freedoms away from from
government and the existing monetary
regimes that we have but uh on the other
hand it does enable stuff like this and
it's sad yeah
um I appreciate you coming in here uh I
really enjoyed this conversation and uh
you're a fascinating guy in terms of uh
kind of running multiple businesses and
uh wish you the best of luck and we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thanks man appreciate it